[Music]  my beautiful four-year-old daughter  Dayla was struck by a stray bullet March  2011 my son my daughter's twin brother  witnessed what happened that day she  died two days later  firearms are the second leading cause of  death for children and teenagers in the  US but 4.6 million American children  live in homes with at least one gun that  is loaded and locked and hundreds of  them gain access to a gun and  unintentionally shoot themselves or  someone else every year as president how  would you address unintentional  shootings by children I'm a 63 year old  boy that's an emoji  [Music]  I was imagining one of them they got  some yes I'm so sorry  [Applause]